Welcome to our Mega Makeover Hour!
(audience applauding)
I'm walking, living proof, I mean, look at me.
I keep walking past the mirror and being like, who is that?
The power of hair and makeup and clothes.
It should be about confidence and empowerment and a feeling,
but it is pretty remarkable
what those things can do to someone.
And we have just sent 25 deserving teachers backstage
for brand new looks and if that isn't the most important,
I don't know what is.
(audience applauding)
But let's answer your biggest questions
and solve all of your beauty and fashion dilemmas,
because our Makeover Mega dream team is here.
It's Chris Appleton, Brandice Daniel and Charlotte Tilbury!
(audience applauding)
Time for a Mega Makeover live,
check in with the amazing Chris Appleton,
who is backstage with our wonderful teacher, Kim King.
Hi, Kim.
(audience applauding)
I wanted to talk to you about a couple of things, Drew.
First of all, humidity, a lot of people-
(Drew laughing)
Humidity and the problems that she has with it.
My go-to is this game changer,
this is the Color Wow, Dream Coat,
this magically transforms the texture of hair
and it actually locks out humidity.
So if the hair, you know, goes into a damp atmosphere
or if you go into a humid atmosphere,
it actually has waterproof technology, so it can't get in.
So we've got your back covered.
And then we also prepped her hair
with the Color Wow Raise the Roof for some extra volume
to really pump up the volume,
'cause she wanted like a glossy, smoother finish,
but she didn't want it flat to her head.
We wanted a little bit of vava voom and a bit of sexiness,
that never goes out of fashion.
Oh, Kim, you are looking so beautiful, you really are.
(audience applauding)
Well, Chris, I'm happy to share with everybody,
that thanks to you, everyone in the audience
is gonna go home with Color Wow's Dream Coat.
Yes.
Okay.
(audience applauding)
So you too can get this look.
It's our Mega Makeover Hour all show long,
we've been transforming 25 amazing teachers backstage
with the help of our Mega Makeover dream team
and it's time for the big reveals.
I mean, dream teams, I can't even believe
I'm standing next to Charlotte Tilbury,
Brandice Daniel and Chris Appleton.
(audience applauding)
So honored, so honored, so honored.
Well, are you ready to show off your work?
Absolutely.
Let's do it.
Alright, we're gonna do a rotation,
first up is Amy, Melissa, Hannah and Stacy, come on out.
Whoo!
Yeah!
(audience applauding)
(melodic upbeat music)
Oh, my God!
Beautiful!
Oh, you guys are so beautiful.
Alright, for this one, Brandice, tell us what you did.
Yeah, you know, it was all about a pop of color.
We're getting ready to go into the spring season
and there is nothing that makes you feel better
than just really bright colors.
Also, if you take a look,
all of them have been accessorized really well
with really great jewelry, really great earrings as well
and so they just all look absolutely beautiful.
How do you feel?
Amazing. (laughing)
That's what we always say, right,
if you look amazing, you feel amazing
and you're beaming, like the rays are just coming out of you
about how gorgeous you look.
And I always say to my daughters,
"Where is it the most important to be beautiful?"
And they go, "On the inside."
(all laughing)
(audience applauding)
I'm like, "Yes, exactly."
Thank you, ladies so much, thank you, thank you, thank you.
So stunning, okay, next up,
four besties from the Southeast Elementary School
in Mansfield, Connecticut.
Their friends and family are in the audience.
Come on out, Liliana, Susan, Kate and Emily.
(audience applauding)
(melodic upbeat music)
Stunning!
(audience applauding)
(melodic upbeat music)
Again, you guys all are beaming with bright smiles.
Kate's husband, Jim is in the audience,
Jim, what do you think?
She looks so different.
I wanted to say though, that Katie and all of teachers
are beautiful before makeovers.
Yeah, absolutely.
But she's amazing now, it's such a transformation.
She looks great.
I couldn't agree more.
Thank you, ladies, you look so great!
You look so beautiful.
(audience applauding)
And next up, we have Porchia, Jackie, Violeta and Mia!
(melodic upbeat music)
Oh my gosh, you guys look so beautiful.
I'm so honored that you guys would give time
to spend with us here today, so that we can honor you.
And Charlotte, may I ask,
what did you do with these beautiful ladies?
Oh, darling, so we put on, I don't know if you've realized
that there's one color, so I've put this beautiful, dreamy,
soft rose pink on you, on me and on all your girls
and it just is a very flattering, universally pretty shade
and I just wanted to prove that if you put that on everyone,
it just makes everyone just glow
and look romantic and soft and beautiful
and it doesn't matter what skin color you have,
what hair color you have, it looks beautiful on everyone.
It's this part of my range,
I see it on you, I see it on you.
And remember you looked in the mirror and you saw your eyes
and we kind of enhanced your eyes.
Everyone's gotta look gorgeous.
Absolutely and so do you, thank you, ladies so much.
Exactly, thank you.
You look so stunning.
(audience applauding)
(melodic upbeat music)